so this panel will deal with issues that
have to do with sociology demography and
urban planning I am Claudia Valencia I'm
a professor here at Yale in the
department of anthropology and in the
department of Spanish and Portuguese and
I'm also the chair of the Council on
Latin American and Iberian studies and I
am very proud of being part of the
organization together with a Ministry of
Education in Brazil of this very
productive gathering I see a lot of
different voices with a common interest
and a lot of potential for synergy and
collaboration and understanding each
other's view of the relationship between
Brazil and the US and we were just
chatting with professor Logan about the
different way the presenters took the
question the discussion question prompt
that we provided and that's an
interesting feature of this gathering
and and I hope you have enjoyed that
freedom as well so for today our
discussion question was regarding
Studies on urban formation and Brazilian
environmental challenges from the u.s.
perspective what are the best ways in
which US researchers can contribute to
the debate in Brazil myself I am an
anthropologist that works with
indigenous people in northern Argentina
and I'm not an expert on issues of urban
formation but I am a very direct witness
of these movements and how the movement
towards urban settings of indigenous
people change their lifestyle change
their health their political economy the
way they relate to each other
so I'm very curious to hear professor
the panelists today professor Fisher and
Professor Logan about how they see
things happening and happen in the past
with Brazil so we are very honored to
have here professor John Logan who is a
professor of sociology at Brown
University dr. Logan completed his PhD
in sociology at the University of
California Berkeley and now he said
Braun and is the co-author along with
Harvey model of urban fortunes fortunes
the political economy of plays his most
recent edited book is diversity and
disparities which was published in 2015
his main ongoing research uses
contemporary and historical census data
to study changes in residential patterns
with a particularly particular emphasis
on immigrants and racial minorities one
set of studies is taking advantage of
recently available 100% census Micro
data in the period of 1880 to 1940 map
in people's location and examining
patterns of neighborhood change and
racial ethnic and class segregation so I
welcome you to your presentation so
we're going to have professor Logan's
presentation followed by Professor
Fischer presentation and then we'll open
up the floor for questions okay good
thank you very much it's a pleasure to
be here I get to hear in such a short
period of time so many people talking
about so many different issues from so
many different perspectives and even in
my own university I I don't get to hear
much from people in other departments
you know we we were quite siloed so
that's been interesting I am NOT a
Brazilian ax stand so when I first was
asked what I
be interested in coming to this meeting
I
I wondered well why why would I do that
and why would anybody ask me to do that
and and what piqued my interest was the
way that this question was formulated
which I understood something to do about
how working from an American perspective
and with with the from an American
perspective what is the contribution
that could be made to people in Brazil
who may be dealing with some parallel
kinds of questions to the ones that we
work with routinely in the US and so I'm
going to do that but I'm going to do it
first of all oh yes so that's a good
question I'm going to talk about it but
I'm going to talk about it not from the
point of view of what I have to
contribute to Brazilian urban studies
but rather an entirely different context
because while not a Brazilian estai am a
China person and I've been working on
China for quite a long time and dealing
very much with exactly the question of
as an American with certain kinds of
resources and reputation and ability to
mobilize things what is it that I could
contribute and and to watch how that's
changed over the years I'd like to talk
about that just primarily as a way to
stimulate your own thinking about what
you take for granted and what questions
you might ask about your relationship
with Brazil the other thing that I want
to do and this really does have to do
with making a contribution to Brazilian
Urban Studies is I want to describe to
you what is stated on this on this title
mapped data for Rio and San Paulo for
2000 and 2010 I want to describe a
system which is a contribution to the
research data infrastructure of mapped
data and a very fine spatial scale on
quite
a lot of indicators that can be used to
study just exactly what is going on with
respect to urban change and
redevelopment in these cities over the
past decade and I'd like to show that to
you if there is any positive result from
this presentation for me any benefit at
all it will be because one of you tells
a friend that by the way did you know
that there's this system available and
you can use it and it might be good for
your classes or for your own research
here's the webpage and I just just one
person that would be enough to make me
happy but let me talk first of all about
this question in general about how an
American social scientist connects up
with another country's background and
for many of you with Brazil you have the
connection that that you are yourself
Brazilian or you have a Brazilian
connection of some kind you were married
to Abbas on your parents or something
like your sort of semi Brazilian with
respect to China I have nothing about
China I don't even speak Chinese so
that's you know I'm kind of an odd
person to be making contributions to
Chinese urban sociology but I had the
opportunity in 1986 at a time when
sociology was just being reintroduced as
a discipline in Chinese universities to
be part of a program that my university
I was at the University at Albany State
University of New York at that time
where we developed a joint ph.d program
between our University and nan Chi
University to recruit the first class of
PhD students in a Chinese university to
get to to get through a program and
several of us went over to Chen Jien and
taught courses and then after three
years we brought everybody to Albany to
work on a dissertation and most of them
got PhDs and I think they all became
professor
because they were the earliest possible
professors of sociology in China so that
was the starting point and obviously
there was a big gap there quite quite a
vacuum the chair of the sociology
department at the time he was he was
actually he was the party secretary and
that was his qualification for the job
he was actually a philosopher a phosphor
of Chinese version Marxism and you know
that's what he contributed to sociology
now nan Chi University has a very strong
program and is capable of growing its
own PhDs within the university it's an
entirely different situation so the
question is how could I contribute and
and one way of course and and we've
talked about exchanges was by helping to
develop the very bright Chinese students
who came to the United States to get a
PhD in sociology and that was also the
way in which I was able to get some
research done myself and get access to
data and have people could explain
things to me and so it was certainly
mutually beneficial but this was also a
period when in sociology in China the
thing they were interested in was
population control this is the 1980s
population control was the sociological
question of the time and I wasn't too
interested in that I wanted people to be
interested in questions about urban
development I thought there were a lot
of good questions in a Chinese context
that would be worth pursuing and I
helped to develop I established a an
urban China Research Network and we got
a grant from the mellon foundation that
made a big difference and we were in a
position to give dissertation research
grants to over about five years to a
hundred young people very small amounts
but at that time even a very small
amount of money was a lot of money in
China and in fact I I I'd say that the
financial relationship between us and
was very much that that they needed that
resource it made a big difference to
them and so I found a way that we could
offer it the interesting thing in that
respect is that now and the urban China
Research Network is quite mature now
most of the people we supported at that
time are the chairs of their departments
of major universities and like it was
very successful in terms of developing a
generation of well-trained scholars so
there was that but the big change is
that I came to realize that there's no
money anymore in the United States to
support urban China research the money's
in China and so everything that we're
doing now is oriented to taking
advantage of the willingness of people
there to support research and their
capability of writing proposals and
getting money from the government and
doing studies that make a real
difference in the local context so I've
been interested in the question well now
what is my role and it continues to be
an important role but it's not a
financial and it's not that I'm going to
teach them the rudiments of sociological
methods or how to work with data or even
what are the questions that we ask in
urban sociology in the United States
that are the cutting-edge questions
because they all have access to that and
they can learn that from their own their
own faculty many have gotten PhDs from
the US but or or European universities
but now they're back and and running the
show in China so what do I have to offer
and one thing is reputation that is is
very helpful in terms of the legitimacy
of the work that people say that they
want to do and their ability to publish
it if they're able to say that it is is
sort of in line with what Professor
Logan said at his talk last year or that
the legitimacy is a very important in
Greece
and hardly substitutable and in the
Chinese context legitimacy is still more
abroad than it is within China and if
you want to publish and have it make a
difference to your career it should be
in an International Journal not a
Chinese based Journal and that's that's
just the way it is so if I can help
people to publish in international
english-language journals that's another
way that like it's not my sociology or
something but rather my ability to work
with them and mentor them as as younger
colleagues the same way I would with
students here in the United States so
that's really a value but it's a it's a
secondary component and so I'm looking
forward to the time when the connection
between the American input into Chinese
urban social science has turned entirely
around to the point that now they are
innovating their own theories of change
their own idea of what needs to be paid
attention to
that they're noticing things that they
can discover from their own fieldwork
and talking to people and living there
that that would always have escaped me
but not only me
but even the American based real China
experts who are also working in the
field so I'm curious about whether that
kind of a relationship or where in that
continuum of a type of relationship
Brazilian studies in the US and
Brazilian studies in Brazil false and
what is the what is it that they need
and what is it that we here can
contribute and are are they now in the
position of how much are they
contributing back to us okay so that's
one that's one thing I wanted to talk
about and I hope I hope some of you
think that that's kind of an interesting
question because we're many of us are
engaged in in doing collaborative work
not just because we want to get our work
done and publish it but because we're
trying to contribute to the development
of a
field somewhere else where it needs to
be developed the other thing I want to
talk about is this mapping system and
now this is a concrete contribution to
research on urban questions in and
Brazil and if the interesting thing here
is that the eBay GAA that's how you
pronounce it in Portuguese has been
collecting and disseminating all kinds
of data for quite a long time and it's
all available on the internet you can
just download it and they even have map
shape files somewhere on the internet
and and if you knew where it was and if
you knew how to use them you could
download them too and you could join the
data to the to the map information and
you'd have and you could do all kinds of
place-based space-based studies of urban
change like where are the favelas or or
do poor people actually live in the
urban favelas or do they live outside
the city and to what extent and how is
it changing and and you know all kinds
of questions about segregation and
advantage and separation by race by
income by age by type of housing is all
available there to study and it's
relatively easy to study if you had the
data in the right format and here's what
I found with respect to this that
although it's all available it's not
really available because it's hard it's
hard to get to it's hard to understand
it's hard to interpret it it's not that
it's in Portuguese that it's hard to
interpret because many of us speak
Spanish so we can read it but to know
what actually was being asked and what
the meaning of the answers was and what
the categories actually are and so on
there's a lot of fine detail that needs
to be understood in addition it's very
hard to know where it is I had
who said oh yeah you can go to their
website and you'll find it so I go to
the website and I can't find it can you
send me a more specific URL there's
there's shapefiles where are the
shapefiles
I I dare you any of you to go find the
shapefiles that show what where what are
the boundaries of the Satori sensit
arias of rio de janeiro in 2000 and I
guarantee it's there but you'll never
find it so so this was the this was the
innovation and I've done this with
American data a lot also in the past but
there is a particular need also with
Brazilian data and again this is one of
the things what can I contribute I don't
think I'm the guy to study urban
neighborhood change and segregation and
advantage and disadvantage and urban
inequality in Brazil because I've only
been there a couple times I hardly know
anything I'm not the guy to do it but I
know how to work with data sets and I
know how to set up dissemination systems
and mapping systems and so on and I can
make that kind of a contribution so here
it is ok let's start with this so an
interesting thing about this system is
that it's built partly on Google so if
you can see it this is in Rio I'm going
to show some examples from Rio de
Janeiro and if you can see it you can
see that there's a neighborhood up in
the upper right and there's a
neighborhood down in the lower left and
they look pretty different from each
other and if you observe it for a while
and think about it for a while you may
be able to figure out what kind of a
place are these two kinds of places
which are quite adjacent to each other
and it's at the West End of the Ponemah
Beach by the way I spent a weekend there
it was really nice you know with my wife
and
and we and we went to the neighborhood
on the other side of the hill and it was
also very interesting but not so nice so
two kinds of settlements and what do we
know about these kinds of settlements so
now I I go away from the satellite image
to say and what is the social content or
the population composition of these
areas and I've I've simply mapped what
percent in small neighborhood areas of
the residents have a college degree
and if you look at this area on the
lower left area it turns out there's two
two different settlements there and then
some big Hills that are kind of in
between them and you say oh it's really
really low like one percent and and then
over on the Ipanema side it's really
really high like 20 or 30 or 40 percent
and well that's interesting to note the
disparity but if you wanted to look more
closely let's see what about done now oh
yes other things about it not just
college degrees but are there street
signs which is a characteristic of the
built environment and what neighborhood
doesn't have street signs on the streets
on the whole and what neighborhood
always has street signs so that's
another kind of a characteristic and we
also know is there piped water is there
piped gas is there litter in the streets
is there there's a number of kinds of
measures about the local local
environment and infrastructure is there
regular trash pickup do the houses have
bathrooms with running water do they so
the ebj actually collected all of this
kinds of data but you wouldn't have been
able to find it but now all you have to
do is you have to go on here and just
click choose a notice there's a menu
here on the upper left please
choose a category and I've chosen
infrastructure and under the category
choose a variable and I chose
neighborhood the percent of neighborhood
that has street signs that's all you
have to do point and click and click and
and you have the results now I'm going
to look more closely at another area
nearby a small part of that what I was
calling Ipanema it's actually LeBlanc
and the travel guide says well okay
that's what it's about
lovely people and looking really close
which you can zoom in in this map system
really really close you see exactly what
kind of housing is high-rise residential
apartments very uniform and the kind of
thing that you might like to live in if
you'd like tall buildings and here is a
much more zoomed in image of the area on
other side now you've been in these
places your students may not have been
in these places and if you'd like to
teach them about places like this then
the visual image is really important for
a sociologist though I'm interested in
things like the college college degrees
education level income level racial
composition street signs quality of the
environment and to be able to link those
all with the visual images so now I'm
going to look at income in the whole Rio
area a larger area and this is where can
you see is there a pointer yeah there's
the I don't know if you can see I'm
moving this pointer around here's where
we were looking and there's the higher
income area and there's right next to it
much lower income air
but the the general story is not about
that area around leb low nor Ipanema the
general story is about there is sort of
central Rio and then there's the whole
periphery and the distinction between
the two and it's really very apparent
when you when you study a map and we can
look further into it
for example I've zoomed into a rich area
at the end of the beach and there is at
the end of it there's a little
neighborhood where I can click on it and
it'll tell me that the income is only
2,300 2,300 something's and the percent
black and brown in that same area is 53
percent whereas in that generally in
that part of the city the the income
level is thirty or forty thousand
instead of three thousand and the
percent black and brown instead of fifty
three percent it's maybe ten percent so
we have very clear very simple ways to
describe the social and economic
disparities among places very close to
one another and because I've used up all
of my time I'm not going to be able to
show you all the rest of the images but
there's more and there's more and
there's not just Rio but there's also
some Paulo and it's not just 2010 it's
also mm so we can see how things are
changing and this is a list of all of
the characteristics that we have in the
map system that you might think would be
interesting to know about so a basis for
a research and I thank you for your
attention
[Applause]
[Music]
Thank You professor Logan and now it's a
pleasure to introduce Brodie Fisher
professor Fisher is a historian of
Brazil and Latin America especially
interested in cities citizenship law
migration race and social inequality and
from 2014 to 18
she was my fellow chair of the Latin
American Center for Latin American
Studies and she will return to the
directorship next year so I was very
interested in her current book
understanding inequality in post
abolition Brazil which explores the
limits of egalitarian and emancipatory
politics in Recife which came to be seen
as both the capital of Brazilian under
development and the incubator of some of
the country's most innovative social and
cultural movements so please join me in
welcoming professor Fisher I'm very
grateful for the invitation to be here -
Claudia - David - the Brazilian Ministry
of Education it's been really
enlightening to hear people come at the
issue of Brazilian studies from so many
different angles it's really an
experience that I've learned a lot from
and I'm in an odd position on this panel
in a sense because I am a historian but
I've made a point in the most recent
phase of my work to try to be a
historian who really crosses over into
discussions of current day events and
particularly issues that have to do with
urbanity with the right to the city with
race and with citizenship and the
meaning of the law in Brazilian society
and so I can't
I was asked here to talk about cities in
particular but I won't be able to quite
shake my identity as a historian in that
I'm gonna subject you to a little bit of
background about the relationship
between US and Brazilian researchers
when it comes to the history of cities
and and the history of the study of
cities before I go on to talk about some
of the things that I think have really
been gained from those relationships and
some of the things that I think looking
forward are especially important for us
to prioritize both here in the United
States but also I hope that that people
in a position to to exercise some degree
of control over over the direction of
Brazilian institutions I hope that these
observations will be interesting for you
as well all right so I was interested in
the formulation of the question for this
panel because it was when I first saw it
I thought well this is an interesting
question because it's really asking
unlike some of the other formulations
for other panels it was asking us to say
what has the u.s. brought to the study
of Brazilian cities or what does the
u.s. bring to the study of Brazilian
cities and as a good guilty imperialist
I immediately thought oh that's the
wrong question because of course it's
not what we bring it's it's a circular
it's it's an exchange but then I came to
think a little bit harder and I realized
well that's actually really an important
question because if I'm thinking about
the allocation of resources in Brazil if
I'm thinking about educational policy in
Brazil where no matter where I am on the
political spectrum in Brazil it actually
matters to think about you know what is
a relationship with institutions in the
United States actually mean what is
gained from a Brazilian perspective from
from having these kinds of relationships
so with the caveat that of course as a
researcher I see these relationships as
being circular as being exchanges in no
way being a one-way street I will focus
my comment a little bit my comments a
little bit more on the question of what
US researchers have have brought to the
table but also have done maybe
unconsciously to to influence the the
field of urban studies in Brazil so to
begin I'm gonna be very schematic
have enough of a sociologist in me to do
that to put things in categories and try
to make them clearer and so I want to
talk about at least three ways in which
I believe that US influence has been
especially important in Brazil really
since the beginnings of the fields of
Urban Studies and sociology in the early
20th century in that country the first
is the most abstract and I want to put
it on the table because I think it's
actually very important for people who
think about urban studies and that is
that the entire conception of what a
city is is still to this day very much a
North Atlantic construction and that's a
problem
because most people who live in cities
do not live in the North Atlantic they
they mostly live in what we incorrectly
called the global South so most people
who live in cities live in cities that
are actually very much unlike the cities
that have created the paradigm for what
a city is supposed to look like so to
make that more concrete whether you're
thinking historically or whether you're
thinking in the in the present tense
there are certain both material and
symbolic signs and symbols that we
associate with what a city is so we
think of a city we think of sidewalks we
think of sewer systems we think of
electricity we think of electric lights
we think of neon signs we think of
cinemas transportation as we move toward
the toward the present tense we think of
soaring skyscrapers maybe our vision
changes to Asian cities rather than the
US or Europe but there is this notion
that the city is part of a kind of
normative architectural spatial and
social evolution and in fact in all of
the stories the modernizing narratives
of the nineteenth and twentieth
centuries within the field of sociology
the city is seen as very much an
incubator of a certain vision of what
the modern is right and this is a vision
that is grounded in Marx and Weber and
in many generations before them actually
but it's a kind of evolutionary notion
of unitary human progress where the city
is some in some ways defined as the most
advanced stage of a particular form of
human evolution now the problem with
that of course
is that that was always even in the
North Atlantic a complete fantasy that
is that cities are much more than that
they're not just the sidewalks and the
sewers and the soaring buildings and the
cinemas cities are also in the in the
United States and Europe as well as in
the global south they are shanty towns
they are forms of violence that are
based not on law and regulation but on
extra legal forms of power they are
places where networks of relational
power are as important as the kind of
liberal legal institutions that we like
to think about when we think about
cities all of those other things exist
in cities no matter where you're looking
at in the world but in a place like
Brazil of course the proportion between
the part of the city that looks like
that North Atlantic ideal and the part
of the city that is misshaped by forces
that we really don't even have very good
sociological categories for is much
greater and so I think from the very
beginning in the beginning of the of the
of the 20th century there's a
fundamentally negative influence that
comes from the US on the study of cities
that has to do with the notion that the
idea of the city that is being projected
to the rest of the world is one that
does not necessarily correspond to what
cities already were in those other parts
of the world and it doesn't necessarily
correspond to what those cities should
or can or want to be and so I put that
out there as a sort of as a dimension of
the relationship between between the
United States and Brazil when it comes
to the production of cities because I
think it's important that actors on all
sides of those exchanges be very
self-critical about what it means to
define the city in a narrow way what it
means to to accept as paradigmatic a
definition of a city that is so limited
and what all of us can do to actually
change those modes of thinking about
what a city ought to be to something
that can actually be more productive in
most of the contexts in most of the
world and so that's kind of a general
theoretical comment on the problem that
I wanted to begin with but from there
I'm going to get much more much more
concrete and I want to talk a little bit
about the really very interesting
history of the creation of urban studies
in the United States and Brazil and the
ways in which those things have been
interdependent and the ways in which
certain kinds of ideas and it's it's not
simply theoretical ideas but also
methodologies and notions about how
cities ought to be studied and what
techniques ought to be used to study
them how those kinds of things have both
been influenced in Brazil by the United
States but how there's also been a
certain amount of circulation of those
ideas and feedback from Brazilian
researchers into the United States so I
think of this second vector as being
direct and scholarly and technical it
involves the creation and the
translation of methodologies and
paradigms that were generally created in
the North Atlantic in the United States
and in Brazil Francis of course also a
very important source England to it to a
smaller degree but the the creation
translation of those methodologies and
paradigms but then the the processes
through which those methodologies and
paradigms arrive in a place like Brazil
and the processes through which they are
adapted and actually become key to the
creation of urban studies as a field in
various Brazilian institutions so I want
to give a very quick and very schematic
summary of that we can actually go all
the way back to the beginning of the
20th century and see these exchanges
happening in things like census sync
techniques and actually as John was
speaking I'll put in a plug for Brazil
the availability of Brazilian data not
just in the present tense but going all
the way back to 1900 I'm working with a
map right now from 1907 that is one of
the first technical maps of his CV and
it is the only map in the world from
that time that our international
collective it has been able to find that
actually maps informality it maps shacks
at that very very early date and so
there's there's really a wealth of this
kind of information to work with over a
long period of time well obviously not
digitized but but it's certainly
something that lots of research could be
done about but already at that point in
terms of conversations about things like
mapping and censuses there was already a
pretty healthy dialogue between US
researchers and those in the United
States but of course one of the crucial
moments in the 20th century in terms of
exchange
was the rise of the chicago school of
sociology and the direct involvement of
some of the members of that school in
researching in brazil but also in
creating some of the first social
science institutions in brazil
particularly it was to be the the
university of sao paulo but also
faculties in rio and in a more indirect
way institutes that ended ups
creating the first anthropology and
sociology programs in the country and
brazilian intellectuals during the 1920s
and 30s were very very deeply influenced
by the chicago school also by the forms
of anthropology and urban what
eventually became urban anthropology
that were being generated in
universities like columbia with Franz
boas but also being really disseminated
among anthropology departments all over
the United States during those years and
so if we read somebody like Schubert or
lady who is of course known mainly for
his ideas or his supposed ideas nobody
very few people who talk about Freddy
actually read him but but there is he's
known for his ideas about race but if
you read his books his his books are
actually as much about cities as they
are about race and the Chicago School
was very influential particularly in his
thinking about evolutionary succession
and the notion of how you adapt that to
a city that rather than having
inner-city neighborhoods and suburbs has
Moe combos or shacks and then their
gradual creation of formal neighborhoods
and he has some very interesting writing
where he uses the Chicago school to
discuss those those kinds of ideas so
you can see the chicago school infernity
you can see of course Donald Pearson
who's probably the most important figure
in the direct transfer of these ideas he
did a study of racial dynamics in Bahia
and Salvador Bahia but also very
important studies of the city of Sao
Paulo and he was fundamental in setting
up the first social science institutions
in Brazil and são Paulo to really think
from a social scientific perspective
about the question of of the city you
also have people like Ruth Landis who
took some of the anthropological
insights that were being generated from
these schools into her study of kondal
bleh
in salvador and there were many
Brazilians who adapted these ideas la
Jocasta panto in Rio is one of the most
important of these he and he and Pearson
were two of the very first people to
begin to do some of the kind of work
that John was talking about in in recent
data to try to take given available
statistics statistics about race and
space and occupation and circulation and
to begin to create a sociology of urban
inequality and particularly racial
inequality in Brazilian cities and so
the very earliest iterations of thinking
about race and space in Brazil were
actually coming about directly because
of interchanges between us and and
Brazilian academics subsequent to that
you of course see the continuation of US
influence on studies of race somebody
like FLOTUS done fernandez one of the
things that's not known about much of
his early work is that it was actually
modeled on on studies of chicago black
metropolis is a very well known book in
the united states the structure of
floaters ten for nine days his first
book about race in Sao Paulo is very
very similar to black market metropolis
and you can see that he's directly
polling many of many of the
methodologies and ways of thinking about
urban space from that place and then you
can go all the way up to the present
tense that someone like head tellus is
taking many of much more sophisticated
modern techniques of being able to map
certain kinds of racial inequality over
time and working with an enormous team
of Brazilian and international
researchers to try to to gain insights
about urban space and segregation and
there are many many Brazilians who are
adapting those techniques now and so
from the 1930s forward particularly on
the issue of race and cities the US
influence I think has been very
important there was also a moment where
US researchers were very important in
transforming debates about urban
informality in Brazil and so at the time
that Brazil was the equivalent of what
perhaps China is now or certain Indian
and African cities are now in various
countries in Africa Nigeria maybe most
particularly Brazil was was in a way
occupying that
partly because of issues that were
brought up a while ago about Brazil's
very particular position in the Cold War
but the notion that the very rapid
urbanization that was happening in
Brazil and other Latin American
countries wasn't somehow it was in some
way a test of the power of modernity and
of the ability of the West to withstand
the communist threat all kinds of
rhetoric that I used to say was
old-fashioned but of course it's now
come back into circulation so I'm not
quite sure what to do with that but but
US researchers who went to Brazil to try
to understand the suddenly visible
phenomenon of the favelas were very
important in creating the fields of
urban anthropology and sociology that
have really come to to be one of the
most important and dynamic aspects of
the Brazilian social sciences in
subsequent years and there's a lot of
detail to those interactions that I
won't go into but they certainly weren't
the first people to talk about favelas
you have the myths of marginality that
Janice Perlman made famous in the United
States those were already being
denounced in Brazil in 1904 and
subsequent generations every generation
has a debate about the myth of
marginality and so it wasn't that US
researchers were bringing these things
for the first time to Brazil but they
were giving a certain kind of visibility
to to these issues in a way that they
had not had transnationally before and
also bringing quite a lot of research of
research funds and support for research
and validation of research that would
have been very difficult particularly
during the military rules to care years
to carry out if it hadn't been for this
relationship with the United States
alright so in the current day of course
there are many many other exchanges that
go back over time I haven't even
mentioned architecture and modernism
which is of course a whole other set of
issues that involve esthetic and art
history questions as well as questions
of urban planning but there there's also
a long history of exchanges about legal
frameworks and rights to the city
legislation many many areas where
there's been this very very fruitful
convergence of Brazilian and US research
but we're especially toward the
beginning of the of the 20th century
u.s. paradigms and ideas had a
formative impact not only on individual
researchers but also on the
institutional structure of urban studies
in Brazil alright so in the time that
remains I just want to very quickly talk
about some of the things that I think
have been gained over time from that
this relationship I'd like to begin by
saying that I think that there are
certain structures that were built in
the United States they're not
necessarily u.s. structures because
actually many of the architects were
immigrants and so to say that this was
something that came from the US and was
sort of broadcast out to the world would
actually be incorrect I mean these are
these are sets of ideas or approaches or
methodologies that were mainly created
by immigrants and the children of
immigrants in US institutions and I
think one of the reasons that many of
these these institutions were so dynamic
is because they were very diverse and
cosmopolitan and implicitly comparative
structures that is even though even when
the thinking was all being done in the
United States it was always being done
in a way that was implicitly comparative
with other parts of the world that
researchers had come from right and so
there is in the very culture of this
early sociology and anthropology a kind
of cosmopolitanism that I think was
really important for the international
development of the field of urban
studies there was also a certain
emphasis particularly in the Chicago
School of methods that were empirical
and inductive and the notion was not so
much that you would begin with a kind of
paradigm and then you would see how it
was applied around the world but it was
that you would send your researchers out
to the rest of the world not only I mean
there was certainly an imperial
dimension to that but also the notion
that you can only really create
Universal knowledge if you're having the
input of all kinds of knowledge that is
built from the bottom up and so there
was a there was an attitude and somebody
like Donald Pearson of not only wanting
to go to Brazil and study Brazil as an
object but also the notion that there
were structures of knowledge although
they might not have used this exact
language that they would absorb and that
would become part of the universal
knowledge of sociology and so there's a
kind of empirical cosmopolitan approach
an inductive approach that I think was
really key to some of the main strengths
of of these approaches and I think that
there's also a certain kind of
multidisciplinary bent that's not in any
way unique to the United States but that
has been very important in urban studies
and I want to use a very contemporary
example to sort of make this clear for
you so we have at Chicago a new
Institute that's called the menswear
Institute for urban innovation and it's
a very controversial on our campus there
are lots of good things there are lots
of things that people criticize about it
but one of the more interesting things
is that the head of this institute is a
man named Luis Bettencourt
who is Portuguese national he speaks
Brazilian he also speaks Portuguese who
was trained as a theoretical physicist
and is housed in the Department of
ecology and evolution so already there
you can see that there's a kind of
radical interdisciplinary approach which
may or may not work in the long run but
that is being brought to this new
Institute for urban studies in Chicago
and that is in some ways the modern
iteration of this interdisciplinary
approach that I think has been very
characteristic of the strongest moments
of us dynamic production about cities in
the past and to make this even even more
concrete one of Luis Bettencourt's areas
of research is to take mathematical
ideas about topology and apply them to
exactly the maps it's almost
serendipitous that John showed us the
maps that he did because if you remember
the grid of leblanc and then the
twisting map of vigil that was right
next to live long in that map what Luis
does is he takes a mathematical
geometric approach to those maps and he
says that if we take one of the main
challenges to the regularization of
urban land which is how can you keep
people in the place where they're living
so don't disrupt their lives and their
social networks and their communities
but yet give them access to the physical
aspects of urban living that are
important to health and safety and
sanitation and all the rest so streets
water systems all of these kind of basic
things of urban life one of the main
problems in doing that kind of work is
that Rio's favelas are full of twists
and turns and alleys and it's virtually
impossible to bring streets into an area
like that without evicting people and so
many of the
clicks that have happened in Rio have
been over this this issue of how can you
regularize without disrupting so he
takes a mathematical approach and he has
built these incredible datasets where he
basically creates a menu of options of
the most efficient ways to make sure
that every house has adequate access to
transportation networks that we might
call streets and so what he does is just
model a million different ways that you
could bring sort of adequate access to
to mobility to urban mobility to one of
these one of these favelas but what's
more interesting still is that he's now
implementing this in Cape Town and in
Mumbai and he's working with an
organization called slums International
which is known internationally for being
a very radical grassroots organization
that is completely against removals
completely against authoritarian
impositions of urban planning and what
they like about this is that these maps
can be taken to community meetings and
they can go through in this very
concrete way these are the options for
getting us to a point where we can have
an adequate amount of access to the city
without disrupting the while disrupting
the minimal number of people within the
community so that's a contemporary
example of this kind of
interdisciplinarity that I think when it
works at its best can actually be what
is most thrilling about the field of
urban studies in general but it involves
bringing all of these fields together in
a way that doesn't happen very often
either in the United States or in Brazil
all right so those are some of the
things that I think have been benefits
just to I know that I'm out of time but
let me just very quickly run through a
few more I think that there is a
inherent quality in the research of
foreigners in other places Tocqueville
was brought up a little bit earlier as
an example of this foreigners can
sometimes see things that are so
normalized for somebody that lives in a
society that they don't seem worth
studying right when you go to someplace
else everything is strange and when you
live in a society everything is normal
and so any healthy society has a certain
amount of energy
interchange between foreigners and
nationals in the United States one of
our biggest problems is that we no
longer have that cosmopolitanism
necessarily in our policymaking circles
that thinks that thinks that the way
that things work here aren't the way
that they have to work and so I think
that kind of injection of a foreign
perspective can be very important
there's also the valorisation of
subjects that are understood as being
taboo within a given context and so in
brazil race is actually probably the
most important example of this that it's
no accident that the issue of urban
racial spatial inequality has again and
again been the focus of the studies of
foreigners or of people who have studied
in the United States and part of that is
exactly what John was saying that if
somebody who is famous and foreign is
bringing this to the center of the table
it's very difficult to marginalize it
and say this is not an issue in our
country right and so there's a certain
kind of exchange and reinforcement that
can happen through that this is also
true about informality as a subject
urban informality as a serious subject
of urban study I think is something that
can be reinforced by foreigners there's
also a very practical dimension of this
relationship which is during the
military dictatorship of course the
United States was a safe haven and a
safe space for researchers including
researchers of race who did not have the
academic freedom the freedom of speech
the funding to continue their research
within Brazilian institutions and I
think it's very very important for us in
the u.s. to take that role seriously
that is that to the degree that we can
be that for people whose free speech is
being threatened in in their own country
and to the extent that sometimes we need
that ourselves and can take advantage of
places like Mexico places like Brazil
that that's a very important part of of
that kind of exchange there's also a
fostering of university cultures that
are diverse separate from politics and
business free and not-for-profit and I
think the US has had a very important
role in fostering those kinds of
institutions in Brazil I'm myself trying
to be optimistic but very concerned
about the future of those particular
qualities in education education that is
no
only for the sake of entrepreneurship
education that really does have a very
deep deep focus on knowledge production
and free speech and that is accessible
to many many sectors of the population
no matter what the race or the
socio-economic background and I think
that there's a lot that we can do from
here to admire the policies that have
been put in place in Brazil and try to
to encourage them and the final thing
that I want to say is that I think that
there's a very important role that most
of us try to take on when we are u.s.
American citizens who work in Brazil and
that is to recognize that usually the
academic work that we are doing about
Brazil when we're really really lucky we
make a contribution to those fields in a
real way and in an intellectual way in a
deep way when we're not so lucky our
best function in the intellectual world
is actually to some extent as people who
are able to translate the incredibly
rich and valuable work that is taking
place in Brazil's universities and think
tanks and intellectual institutions and
as people who can help to diffuse those
ideas in the United States and I think
that the problem of translation is one
that we often tend to minimize because
we say oh no you know so many Brazilians
speak English and they publish in
English and you know we've really gone
past the time where there's really a
very important role for translation but
the fact is that both Brazilians and
people from the US who study Brazil
there's a lot to translation that goes
beyond the literal linguistic
translation in order to make people in
the United States understand the meaning
of the very rich debates that happen
within Brazil you need intermediate
figures and those can be brazilians with
long experience in the United States or
in Europe or they can be Europeans or
people in the US who have long
experience in Brazil but you need these
intermediary figures who can demonstrate
to their own culture in my case the
importance and the validity of the
knowledge that is being generated in
Brazilian institutions for universal
debates because many many Brazilians
don't need any help with that at all and
they're already the most important in
election
figures throughout the world but in my
own fields of Urban Studies in history
there are so many brilliant people whose
work is unknown outside of Brazil
because of the barrier because of the
linguistic barrier but also because
Brazil ironically has such a fantastic
university culture that people do the
same thing they do in the United States
they speak to each other and they don't
speak to an outside world and so I think
there's a very important function that
that we ought to play in the United
States in that collective task of
translation and valorisation too close
I'd like to say that one of the only
reasons that I ever went to work in
Brazil and one of the only reasons that
I ever loved to have Brazilian visitors
both faculty and students come through
the University of Chicago the reasons
that I stay engaged with the country the
reasons for that is not just that I like
the beach although I do it's not just
that whenever I go to Brazil I just have
a feeling of being in a place where
where I want to belong it's not just
that it's also that of all of the
countries that I've worked in outside of
the United States when I went to Brazil
there was so much at a purely
intellectual level that I realized that
I had to learn and this was true in
terms of the level of the intellectual
debates that I was seeing and think
tanks and universities it was true in
terms of a scholarship that has taken me
25 years to feel like I have a grasp of
because it's such an enormous and
complex and diverse set of scholarship
and it's true in terms of the pure area
dition that is such a quality of a
really good Brazilian education in which
many people from the US actually can
feel quite ignorant when they're when
they're exposed to it and all of those
things are the result of educational
institutions that at their very best at
the university level really work well
and I think that I share with many of my
colleagues in the United States a hope
and a commitment to trying to make sure
that Brazil continues to be a place that
is so generative of ideas that transform
the way that we universally understand
issues like cities and inequality and
law and history and part of that is
really being vigilant to make sure that
in the transformation of the things
don't work about a system there's also
value given to the things that really do
work and so I wanted to end by just I
hope sharing or or articulating
something that most of us share which is
the most important dimension of the
exchange at a university level between
the United States and Brazil is the very
high quality of the the thinking and the
research and the production that's
happening in Brazil it wouldn't happen
if it wasn't such an interesting
exchange and it's really important for
that to stretch into the future I thank
professor Logan the professor feature
for their presentation and open the
floor for questions
let me start I want to I want to
congratulate Brody on her presentation
it was really an unusually sophisticated
overview and I don't often hear that at
conferences so thank you let me just
start with a with a provocation what if
we posit that collaboration is not a
good that it's not an unmitigated good
my colleagues sociologists of knowledge
tell me that in certain types of
problem-solving research teams to design
a fast algorithm it can be good to
separate teams of researchers at the
beginning have four or five separate
teams that do not communicate and only
bring them into communication at the end
end stage of the of the process we we
have a tendency I think in the name of
academic freedom in the name of
untrammeled communication to assume that
it's always great that everyone should
be talking all the time so moving from
my provocation to the kind of
collaboration that we know and then and
and that we need what could strike a
balance between what's good in national
or local or university
scientific communities let's call them
that and the cosmopolitan scientific
communities that or networks that we
that we join well I'll say something
about that and then I'll turn it over to
Brody who I think will do a better job
to bring it down to the Brazilian case
first of all we don't organize ourselves
around a project in the social sciences
we have ten thousand or twenty I don't
know how many thousand people working in
on different kinds of things and even if
I limit it to urban studies then we have
at least a thousand people are really
really active and doing something and
somewhat know what each other is doing
some what are influenced by what a what
the other people are doing and so on
we're really very very disconnected and
the connections that do exist are often
very much at a local level certainly
within national communities but within
national communities even within a
particular network within that country
usually so so mostly what we have to
begin with is dis separate from the
beginning disjointed teams working on
but not necessarily on the same project
so it is so unlike this idea that you
that you set up with your provocation
but but I want to take it further too
and so well what could be good and what
could be bad about it so what can be bad
about it is the degree to which these
little networks are insulated from each
other and just don't know what's being
done by people elsewhere especially I
think between like sociologists and
economists and anthropologists like we
tend not to read each other's work
unless it becomes really you know high
reputation work and then you read it oh
that's interesting but then kind of put
it aside because it's not
it's so the Disciplinary thing but in
addition there's we have divisions among
ourselves about theoretical orientation
some urban sociologist would be very
upset to hear the Chicago School talked
about in terms of something that ever
had any positive influence at all in the
world and well in any way so there are
these kinds of divisions right and and
that create an inability of us to talk
to each other and learn from each other
and so I'm gonna say from the very
beginning given how fragmented our world
is everything that we can do to push for
just a little bit more coordination and
collaboration now I want to say just one
more thing about how it can work badly
and that is when it gets to be within we
have power structures within academia we
have power structures networks and it
would be possible to imagine a world in
which for example all of the Brazilian
social scientists have relatively little
power and they're guided by non
Brazilians who have a lot of power and a
lot of resources and a lot of influence
and you could imagine such a world in
fact the world might have been like that
at some time like in the Italian
academic system where the professor
controls everything and if you're lucky
eventually he'll die and you can be a
professor you know like this is this is
kind of a bad world a more egalitarian
world a world in which more people have
access to the raw materials that are
required to do stuff in history to have
all the materials digitized in
demography to have all the census data
transcribed and available in an easy
form to get to and you know that's
that's that's that's what I look for a
democratization of the
pasady to do work and that's very hard
to achieve especially in an Anglophone
dominated world so I'll give you a
chance get on that box I'm gonna try to
be very very brief I definitely accept
the provocation and actually I think in
some ways that's why I began with the
first idea that I began with that is
that when we have a constantly connected
conversation there's a tendency for the
power dynamics of intellectual
production to create a conversation
that's based on ideas that make more
sense for one area of the world than for
another and so that's one of the dangers
of too much communication is that we end
up with these the common language
becomes paradigms that are generated one
place and don't apply to other places
and so I think that that that's one of
the the biggest risks but I think that
actually the the ideal balance in some
ways is one that in the best of
circumstances we actually have in urban
studies now that is that you have a
place like this and reduced reduced on
metropoli which is a sub Paulo
think-tank on urban issues very
interdisciplinary really brilliant
people gabrielle felt wrong eduardo mark
is really wonderful social scientific
thinkers in brazil and they're
developing categories of analysis and
information that really are very
different than something that you would
come up with if you were thinking from
the United States or from Europe and yet
they are networked enough that they're
able to broadcast and translate those
ideas so that they are put into
circulation and the reason that they can
develop the ideas that are so different
is because they've come through a system
where there is support for domestic
knowledge production at a rich and
intense level and when you have that
kind of support what it means is that
the place that you come from ends up
being able to contribute to
international conversations on an equal
footing it's not it's not people who
don't have research resources who are
talking to people who do it's people who
are coming from positions of equal equal
resources and equal advantage and so I
think the best way to to avoid that
particular danger is to just make sure
that there's a very robust system in in
every place that's good
participating in the conversation and
that's the equivalent of separating
people into groups first right you come
up through your educational system in
such a way that you're able to develop
your own way of understanding the world
before you end up in this conversation
with other other places
I guess just to add to that one of the
things that seems to me that was
responsible for creating that
infrastructure in Brazil was not just
investments in higher education which
happened substantially over the past few
years but also investment or a lot of
care for some development policies in
areas like racial equality Social
Development and Urban Development
because when you have the when you have
need in the government for knowledge on
how to tackle some issues and advance
some policies I guess that creates a lot
of excitement in the academic community
and that galvanizes a lot of the energy
that's available down there I mean how
do you see the future for for Brazil
given changes that seem to be happening
I think that's a topic for at least a
year of discussions I mean I think that
you've you've absolutely pinpointed it
it comes down to it's not only whether
or not there will be some kind of
constitutional amendment that changes
free access to education or whether
there will be any repealed formative
action it's not just a legislative
question but it's also in a system where
the where the state has been such an
important financier of research and
where state agencies are responsible for
so much of the research time that people
spend not only in public universities
but also in private universities the
question of what kind of contract work
will be available what kinds of projects
will be funded what kind of knowledge
will will be encouraged I think that's
absolutely fundamental and that's I
don't think anyone has an answer in
terms of I mean certainly most of my
friends are very worried about the
availability of funding for the kinds of
projects that are understood as being a
political and a themá-- to to the
government that's coming in I hope that
they're wrong but but I think it's a
very it's a very substantial worry and
and it is a place I think
where the US can play a very concrete
role if that happens that is similar to
what happened when the Ford Foundation
published research on race and cities
and Brazilian society in the 1970s and
80s that is that there's a place for
international funding to keep going some
of the projects that are the most
dynamic and the most vital to Brazilian
society and if things go in a direction
where vital research has been cut off
for political reasons then I think
that's a really important thing for us
to think about from from this
perspective I'd like to just mention a
different context and go back to the
Chinese case I I mentioned earlier that
when I first went to China sociology was
understood by the government to be
understanding how to control the
population growth and how to maintain
the one-child family and that no that
was it
now the government is interested in
income inequality and in the
marginalization of rural urban migrants
as key social issues they cloak it in
the discussions of with words like
social harmony and you know that you
know they have their way of talking
about it but this is what they're this
is what they're really interested in and
they're supporting they created the
Ching hua University sociology
department specifically to have a
mechanism for focusing research on on
social inequality and it's it's
pervasive now throughout the system so
that the conditions under this
particular authoritarian but worried
about maintaining itself into the future
regime are really very good for a
progressive sociology 15 years ago 20
years ago when I was beginning to do
research myself and I was interested in
similar kinds of issues of inequality I
had to say I was interested in housing
and housing reform because it was it was
legitimate but there was a way to study
this and and and
other people followed that that got to
two core questions but in a form that
was politically acceptable and I suppose
in the Brazilian case and probably
people will find such ways that is
they're really going to study this but
they'll find a way to study it that
doesn't look like it's attacking the
regime the but the other possibility is
that the outsider and I was of course in
the Chinese case very much the outsider
could come in and and find ways to
support that that that made a difference
I think I'm sure this is true there's a
there's so much stronger a Brazilian
studies community in the United States
and Europe that's available to bypass
and I don't think you need the Ford
Foundation or the something foundation I
think that there's enough of a critical
mass in the Academy to to push things
forward in the worst case is that wrong
is that is that too optimistic do people
think that's too optimistic because I
don't know that I don't know Brazil I
don't know this guy so I just wonder
what do people how many people think
that's too optimistic how many people
think this guy is falling I would like
to propose that we take a seven minute
break to think about this and convene
back at 3:00 for our next panel thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]